[Music]
most people were asleep when Russia
Unleashed its wave of cruise missiles
this apartment Block in uman in central
Ukraine devastated in the attack
Moscow claims it does not Target
civilians but this is the reality
[Music]
laughs
oh that's funny
as morning broke firefighters continued
to search for survivors those that did
Escape traumatized
um
other cities were also struck in the
nepro in the southeast of the country a
mother and her two-year-old daughter
were killed in the bombardments
[Music]
Capital also did not Escape unscathed
although its defense systems did manage
to down most of the missiles this
apartment block was hit by debris as
they were intercepted
and despite the threats in a show of
solidarity EU leaders continued with a
visit to the city to meet President
Vladimir zelensky
the fighting in the east of the country
remains intense with Russian forces
continuing their assault but Ukraine is
expected to launch a counter-offensive
in the coming weeks
for civilians the pain of this war is
unending in Oman they're continuing to
recover bodies with the threats of more
attacks ever present
Alex Rossi Sky News